this is the brand-new 16 inch of MacBook
Pro this is pretty much everything that
I think we have all wanted in an upgrade
in the MacBook Pro we have a bigger
screen faster performance better battery
life more RAM can spec this thing out to
an 8 terabyte solid state drive and 64
gigs of ram and of course Avery a design
keyboard although I have had no problems
with my butterfly keyboard but this is
now using a new scissor mechanic and
that keyboard design is being modeled
after the magic keyboards that we all
love to come with the IMAX this 16 inch
MacBook is now going to be replacing the
15-inch models so let's unbox this and
take a first look at the brand-new 16
inch retina macbook pro how many times
am I going to say 16 inch retina macbook
pro in this video probably like 500 it
does come in two colors the silver and
the Space Gray so this is the Space Gray
version
oh my gosh I need a moment this smells
like red velvet cake the new MacBook is
4.3 pounds the previous gen 15-inch that
I have right here which looks like an
absolute mess is four pounds
side-by-side comparison just in my mind
I know that this one is heavier but I
just holding the two I can't really tell
you're wondering what this is on my old
MacBook this is velcro that I used to
attach my external hard drives to this
MacBook will soon be getting the velcro
treatment but not right now because it's
too beautiful and pristine this has the
same IO ports as the previous gen it has
for us BC and Thunderbolt three ports
you can also connect to Pro X to Y our
displays got a chance to see those
things at WWDC and up close they are so
beautiful of course we have our USBC
cable I think we've all seen one of
these before
are there Apple stickers perhaps in
their Space Gray the new charging brick
is now 96 slots so they made this a
little bit more powerful but it still is
same size and form factor as the
previous bricks that was like a nice
paper field usually it's like a plastic
you can get this in two different
configurations
there's the 2.6 gigahertz six core Intel
i7 and there's a 2.3 gigahertz eight
core Intel Core i nine let's move this
thing up and what's really exciting is
this entire video drivers are watching
right now I'm going to be editing on
this macbook oh my gosh it's already
starting up I'm gonna get this thing set
up I'll see you guys in a second third
things now set up because I have I
thought on all of my files are synced so
my terrible messy desktop that I have on
my other laptop is now populating onto
this one one of the biggest highlights
for this new keyboard is the return of
the actual physical Escape key if you do
a lot of coding or programming even an
editing I need that Escape key and
having it be just on the digital touch
bar but sometimes have to do several
presses to get back to that but now the
Escape key is back and they also
redesigned the arrow keys this is also
going back to one of the older designs
because the new butterfly keyboard these
arrow keys the left and the right are
full-size squares and it's basically the
same size as the up and down the
speakers have also been updated they
have a new a6 speaker sound system and
they have an updated microphone it's
supposed to give you studio quality
recording and a three microphone array
let's say stop these speakers by
listening to what I always test out with
music tool
[Music]
oh my gosh is this loud this sounds
incredible so but open up GarageBand now
I'm gonna test out what it sounds like
using the internal microphone the new
MacBook is also shipped with Catalina
which is great because I honestly
haven't updated my current MacBook yet
so this is really the first time that
I'm getting to have a MacBook experience
with Catalina
so first let's test the audio on the new
16 inch MacBook Pro hi hello this is
Justine reporting to you not live in a
room that is slightly echoic so if you
do hear a little bit of that background
noise that's because I'm in a massive
room that is not soundproof now let's
move on to the previous gen 15-inch
MacBook Pro looking at these two things
side by side Wow I cannot wait to get to
editing on this thing so let's take a
look at the size comparison obviously
this one is larger because it is a
larger screen surprising that it's not
that much larger considering you're
getting an entire inch more of screen
real estate well here's the size
difference between the 15 and the 16
inch tell right around here but the real
difference is looking at the screen
where they are side-by-side and if you
take a look you can notice the smaller
bezels
around the side of the new macbook as
opposed to the old one and obviously you
can tell everyone is the old one not
only by the smudges but by the size of
the bezels so the screen brightness on
both of these is the same it's 500 nits
the trackpad is also the same size and
again the keyboard is where the real
updates also live so the keys are a
little bit more tactile so I feel like
when you're pressing down you actually
feel like you're pressing a real key as
opposed to the butterfly keyboard it's a
little more gentle I guess you could say
but I'm really excited about these
upgrades especially having these
separate Escape key the updated arrow
keys and also this standalone touch ID
button I'll be doing a bigger video
diving into some more of the great
things about this MacBook but since this
is just the first look the initial
reaction to seeing this screen like it's
larger but it doesn't feel like the
overall footprint of the computer is
actually larger I'm sure many of us
remember the 17-inch MacBook
that they used to have and those things
just felt significantly larger we also
felt really heavy this feels like I'm
almost using my 15-inch MacBook but just
with a larger screen I'm gonna plug this
in because I have to hop on a flight
here very shortly and I'd like to have a
full battery for the flight so I could
edit and speaking of battery not only
have they managed to put the largest
capacity battery that you can put in
here that it will allow you to so fly
with this it's powering faster
processors a larger screen and you'll
still get an extra hour of battery life
they're saying that it'll get about 11
hours of battery where does the 15-inch
you'll get 10 hours and obviously
battery life it depends on what you're
doing for me when I'm editing there is
no way I would get 11 hours of battery
life but any extra battery life is
appreciated like the charging break
would give us more power I mean this
thing is so incredibly powerful when you
think about how much they have crammed
inside of this macbook it's shocking
especially an 8 terabyte solid-state
drive trying to get an 8 terabytes
solid-state drive right now just as a
portable drive is almost impossible to
have that internal on your computer is
so amazing not only for me as a video
editor is this gonna be incredible
because obviously huge file sizes but
right now I'm lugging around 2 terabyte
solid-state drives that are just
portable but now with 8 terabytes like
I'm not even gonna need to be editing
off of those externals anymore for
photographers you'll be able to store
all of your RAW images directly on here
you won't have to edit from separate
drives and I cannot wait to test out the
sidecar since I've been holding off on
updating to Catalina for final cut
specifically I'm excited about using
that when I travel because I'll be able
to have all of my files and use that as
a file browser and I can just be
focusing on doing most of my editing and
color correction directly on the math
book another pretty impressive thing is
they have managed to make the price of
this computer the same price as the
15-inch MacBook so you'll be able to get
one of these starting at 23 99 as the
base model and the 9 core is $27.99
which is pretty impressive if you think
about it so basically they're taking
this new 16 inch and replacing the 15
inch pro model and still managing to
keep it the same price ok this was just
a first look at the new macbook pro I am
really excited because my entire life
revolves around video editing production
and being on the go so being able to
just have this device this is really
going to change everything
obviously the 15-inch MacBook Pro that I
had previously was beyond incredible
I've edited so many videos on that thing
and now just with the increased speed
and the amount that I am traveling I was
able to have a much faster turnaround
time I'll be doing some further testing
and video editing and really pushing
this thing to the limits but for now I
have to hop on a plane and I'm gonna
take this footage that I've shot right
now and I'm going to edit this video for
you guys the time to transfer footage
for the first time onto the new MacBook
Pro so I've been shooting with the
atomos Hodges and he's all recording
externally to solid-state drives so
we'll just plug this in and we're going
to transfer our first set of data to the
new Mac
[Music]
- talent I like to call this eating
just landed this is basically a less
than 24 hour turnaround time video I
have been editing all day we shot all
day now I'm gonna get some dinner when
you're done entirely different states
I'm actually naturals about Good Morning
America this week so that's super
exciting but of course that never stops
I'm so close to finishing this video I
just honestly cannot believe how fast
this computer is it is so fast even
compared to my previous gen containers
MacBook which is completely Specht out
back to editing I'll see you guys in a
second
[Music]
it's cold
and here's my final edits I am
officially exhausted I'm not even sure
how long this is consecutively took me
because I have been editing so
sporadically throughout this trip but
the video is done and the one thing that
I did notice is because this has
increased cooling they have all new fan
architecture and I definitely notice the
difference because I edit a lot with my
MacBook sitting on my lap and normally
you can tell if the computer starts
getting hot the fans will start spinning
up and the processes will start slowing
down a little bit but this time I was
editing a lot in the car with the laptop
on my lap and it stayed significantly
cooler than my previous gen definitely
looking forward to testing this out more
I was going to shoot more of a recap for
you guys but basically I'm loving it so
far it's super fast I look forward to
testing this out more so let me know if
there's anything specifically you guys
would like for me to test on here if you
have any questions be sure to ask me
them in the comments below and I will
try to answer some in the next video in
the meantime me in this laptop and my
air pods or going to bed see you soon
Internet
[Music]